170 000 u.s military personnel are
deployed overseas
of them about 60 000 or 35 percent are
stationed in japan more than any other
country
in fact only two germany and south korea
even come close
and while this number has been slowly
declining in most places troop
deployments in japan are actually on the
rise
its islands are home to over 80 american
bases and the navy's only
forward-deployed aircraft carrier uss
ronald reagan
the u.s japan alliance is among the
strongest in the world
in the last century japanese leaders
have made more state official and
official working visits to the us than
any other ally
the public in both countries also
overwhelmingly view the other favorably
71 percent of japanese and 87 percent of
americans
yet there has always been a fundamental
sense of imbalance
the united states is unquestionably
japan's closest ally
but japan is only one of many close
american allies
one needs the other for its continued
existence whereas the other only wants
the benefit of cooperation
for being friends the two countries
exchange a whole lot of money leading
many to wonder
who gets the better deal
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
where you can watch this bonus video
about japan's almost nuclear deterrence
the relationship between the us and
japan has never been normal
unlike nato allies who are committed to
defending one another theirs is
one-sided
while the u.s is bound to protect japan
which it accomplishes through its
extended nuclear deterrence the reverse
is not true
instead the arrangement began as a
strategic trade security in exchange for
bases which gave the american military a
front row seat in asia
it was agreed that japan would provide
all the facilities airfields and ports
while the us would pay for everything
else
at the time all this seemed perfectly
fair japan after all was then completely
devastated by the war
in fact it could very easily be argued
that as the victor the us took advantage
as time went on however japan only got
richer and richer
so too did the yen gain in value
the circumstances had changed
dramatically yet the deal had not
and so under pressure from the americans
in 1978 japan began making payments
above and beyond what was required by
the treaty
because these payments were designed to
demonstrate understanding for the costs
monetary and otherwise shouldered by the
americans they became known as the
sympathy budget
the u.s prefers the term host nation
support
while making clear this was completely
voluntary japan built new facilities
paid their utilities and covered the
salaries of its citizens who worked in
them
then two things happened which raised
concerns of loyalty
first japan refused to help secure the
persian gulf during the iran-iraq war
despite being explicitly asked to do so
by the u.s
and second toshiba was caught around the
same time selling military technology to
the soviets
the country was at serious risk of being
seen as a bad ally
it knew it had to do something
that something turned out to be
formalizing the previously voluntary
annual payments into contracts called
special measure agreements to be
renegotiated every five years
japan's contributions climbed
immediately to a new high
in the 40 years between 1978 and 2016
japan paid something like 65 billion
dollars in total for u.s forces with an
average increase of 17 percent a year
in 2019 it contributed roughly 3.16
billion dollars to the u.s military when
everything from labor to utilities the
cost to relocate training exercises away
from civilian populations and facility
upgrades are included
but what do these numbers really mean
you may wonder
in 2017 japanese politicians claimed the
country shoulders 86 of the total cost
to station u.s troops there
the pentagon came up with 74 percent in
2004
other sources go as low as 50 percent
whatever the true figure it's higher
than south korea around 40 percent or
germany 32.
none of these numbers however are
complete
many contributions simply can't be
quantified
these include things like indirect
subsidies the infrastructure around
bases like roads waived taxes and fees
and quite substantially the rents that
could have been collected from the land
occupied by bases
last but not least japan buys nearly all
its defense equipment from the us
the biggest sacrifice made by the
japanese government however is not
monetary but political
politicians are caught between two very
powerful forces
on one side is the public who
overwhelmingly opposes militarization
anything resembling an expansion of the
military will be met with intense
scrutiny
no party no matter how popular can
afford to ignore the will of voters on
this issue
which means very carefully tiptoeing
around the entire subject of defense
in 2015 for instance shinzo abe passed a
security law allowing the military to
protect its allies under certain
circumstances in addition to
self-defense a right so basic and
universal that it's enshrined in the
united nations charter
for this he paid dearly as you can
clearly see in this graph of approval
rating
on one day alone 300 protests were
staged across the country the largest of
which attracted 120 000 people
shinzo abe's relative success and
politics came despite his perceived
hawkishness not because of it
in the run-up to elections he would
cleverly shift focus to the economy
only turning to defense after he had won
on the other side is the united states
in america where no equivalent peace
culture exists japan's unwillingness to
expand the size and role of its military
is not some noble commitment to pacifism
but somewhere between greedy and
dangerous
many would like for it to take on a
greater share of the financial burden
for the sake of fairness
others including much of the foreign
policy establishment see japan as
relying too heavily on the us at the
expense of its own military and
ultimately the security of the entire
asia-pacific region
thus japanese politicians must carefully
balance these two forces in the short
term satisfying the demands of voters or
else losing power
while simultaneously meeting the rising
long-term expectations of its ally or
else losing its sole source of
protection
this tension came to a head during the
first gulf war
in december 1990 the u.s ambassador
called the japanese prime minister on
the phone asking a long-standing ally
for support against the iraqi invasion
of kuwait
but doing so was deemed unconstitutional
in one poll just one third of
respondents supported sending forces
though with one hilarious condition that
they not be armed
in the end japan refused
only after a ceasefire was announced did
it send six small vintage wooden mine
sweeping ships
even this was controversial back home
the international community was furious
instead of sending forces japan
contributed cash
13 billion dollars or 20 percent of the
total cost though it stipulated the
money could only be used for non-lethal
purposes
yet with zero casualties to the us's
over 100 it didn't sit right
japan was accused of checkbook diplomacy
paying money to dodge its obligations
rather than doing the noble thing and
putting lives on the line
in truth its assistance was far from
necessary the victory came easy
it wasn't about money or need it was
about fairness
japanese politicians chose to obey the
will of voters who opposed the war but
in doing so lost a great deal of
international credibility
but the lesson stuck
ten years later on september 11 2001 it
took the japanese government just 45
minutes after the attack to set up a
task force and declare its full support
for the us
within a month japan had passed an
unprecedented law that would later allow
boots on the ground in iraq despite
popular opposition and protests
since then its troops have been sent to
cambodia mozambique rwanda and a dozen
other countries
but this is not quite what it seems
the government only managed to sell this
dramatic shift in defense policy at
least by japanese standards by imposing
insanely strict restrictions on itself
the law only permits deployments of up
to two thousand troops only for un
peacekeeping operations and only if five
specific conditions are met
the japanese self-defense forces are
forbidden from infantry tasks including
doing things like collecting weapons and
can only operate in areas explicitly
deemed safe
japanese troops often require dedicated
protection from troops of other nations
which is sometimes derisively labeled
babysitting
they arrive only after bullets have
stopped flying leave at the earliest
sign of trouble and because they're
forbidden from protecting allies are
sometimes more liability
none has ever died on a mission overseas
and a single death would instantly
trigger a crisis back home
this solution in other words nearly
satisfies both parties the public and
the us
but only marginally
the trouble is that these two opposing
forces continue growing further apart
over time
contrary to expectations young japanese
even without a visceral memory of the
war have not waned in their cultural
inclination towards peace
yet the american public and by extension
decision makers increasingly demand more
from its allies
and while accusations of unfairness
reached a fever pitch during the trump
presidency they are by no means new
whoever the president and whatever the
global circumstances japan faces the
same basic dilemma
public opposition prevents it from ever
taking control of its own defense
destiny
yet only one country can fill this hole
the united states
in short japan has one option and one
option only
who wouldn't be anxious
if it were ever threatened with war it
would have no choice but to hope for
protection by the us
that is except for one very last resort
the nuclear option if you will
in this bonus video i explain how japan
could acquire nukes in a pinch
you can watch this and other entirely
exclusive bonus videos on nebula the
streaming platform built by and for
creators
some of my favorite recent nebula
originals are legal eagles bad law words
good and second thoughts the new f word
best of all you can get access to nebula
and curiosity stream home to great
documentaries on history nature and
technology like this one looking back at
world war ii together for just 15 bucks
a year
sign up by clicking the link on screen
now and get both nebula and curiosity
stream for this incredibly low price